foreign
over 70 years old
so in about a year and a half two years
I'm gonna have to start taking uh
cuts from my 401k automatic payouts the
government make sure yeah you're
required minimum distribution yeah right
I don't use that money it just sits
there it was making money under the
Trump Administration it's kind of losing
money right now yeah anyway uh I don't
really know what to do with that money
because I don't need it but I want my my
gut feeling is to invest it in Gold no
no no no we don't put anything in Gold
no if you don't need it and You're Gonna
Let You Wanna let it sit somewhere let
it sit in a good mutual fund that's fine
that would do better than gold oh
absolutely I I I I own some gold cuff
links and that's the only gold I've got
okay I I just don't want to do anything
risk at this point that risky is goals
gold is much more gold is much more
volatile if you look at the price of
gold on a chart it's way up and way down
much more than the stock market is a lot
riskier and it does not yield the net
return the average annual rate of return
on gold sucks
really yeah that's awful yeah I I don't
know that much about it I've just heard
that gold was a good good investment so
yeah usually from people that don't have
any money
that that 4 that 401k will just be part
of my daughter's inheritance that's cool
that's cool you're gonna pull that money
out of the 401K that we're talking about
because you're required to and I would
just be moving it into good good mutual
funds in in the process uh I think I I'm
gonna ask a question on behalf of maybe
new listeners maybe somebody's never
heard you talk about this why are you so
emphatic about gold and well we know why
it's up and down why is it so up and
down because the way it's sold is well
if the dollar gets hurt you need gold I
mean that's the fear message that's
behind this why is gold so volatile
gold is a commodity
okay it's a it's a it's a rock that is
yellow
okay
you have barrels of oil
you have
uh precious metals diamonds
Commodities corn commodity
and commodities are all traded one
hundred percent based on people's
perception of shortage
if the perception is that there's a no
shortage that there's too much of it the
price goes down
so like the the old movie orange juice
Futures with Trading Places with Eddie
Murphy which was a mythological future
okay there weren't orange juice Futures
but
um but it was fun for the movie's sake
but all that is is you're you're you're
betting on and commodities are all more
volatile than Investments that actually
create Revenue so in investment that
creates revenue is a company that's
running that makes a profit Home Depot
makes a profit
Microsoft makes a profit and it's either
a lot of profit or not much profit Apple
makes a profit a lot of profit and so
their stock goes up based on the fact
that they are creating Revenue gold and
corn and oil does not create Revenue it
only trades based on scarcity and
people's perception that scarcity is
greed and fear
and it's like I'm afraid so I'm going to
rush towards it and if a whole bunch of
people Rush towards it it creates a
shortage and the price goes up but
that's the only thing that causes the
price go up the gold did not become more
valuable just more people were chasing
fewer bars
that's all it is Supply demand drives it
up and so anytime you're investing in a
commodity you are at the mercy of the
psychology of the marketplace
Everybody's scared or everybody's greedy
and they're chasing two things so that's
the only way price is established where
if you buy a piece of income producing
real estate price is established based
on the income it creates
not based on oh it's real estate you
know it's not oh it's a golden Rock okay
so the golden Rock has no magical
qualities
it's a rock
it's a golden Rock
diamonds don't have magical qualities
they're a little clear thing and they're
not necessarily a girl's best friend
that is a marketing slogan by people who
sell diamonds yes because diamonds do
not go up in value I've got quite a lot
of them
hanging around my wife yes yes so um and
and let me tell you how much they've
gone up while I've owned them not right
at all right so for people that are so
rate of return is called marriage but
there is no actual investment return on
the stupid things they're a complete
waste of freaking money otherwise so
give us uh 30 40 seconds on these
headlines that people are seeing and
that's why we get this call in Gold
they're seeing all the Dollar's in
danger China's making moves Russia it's
in the headlines all the time what
should they do when they hear these
headlines about the dollar and it's the
danger in the dollar well the number one
you can't run to Gold there's nothing
magical about it okay number two Brazil
and China and Russia our large land
masses
but Russia and Brazil are not large
economies
their gross domestic put output is very
low Texas has a larger gross domestic
production than Brazil
Texas is a bigger economy than Brazil
so do you think that Brazil and any of
their little friends are going to snipe
the dollar not a chance they're going to
have to do business with the 800 pound
gorilla and we do business in dollars so
they're going to be at our Mercy still